hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we are going to talk about
Marvel Sony spider-man far from home mr.
stark
it's my Tom Hall I got it sorry we will
be doing a spoiler talk for you guys is
there's plenty of things to talk about
as a matter of fact half tempted to just
skip this non-spoiler review and just
hop on this floor stalkers are so many
things that you can spoil that go on in
this film especially those post-credit
scenes well a lot to talk about it got
Andrew Gordon coming by I know you guys
love him before we go into this I want
to say a special thank you to the folks
over at RealD 3d and 4d exited a combine
screening for this where you get to
experience the 40 X motion of the chairs
and the effects that you've heard us
talk about countless times I always set
them up for the screen I hit them up if
they have a screening going on and then
of course the real d3d a lot of eye
poppin visuals more here than in
homecoming some sequences we can't get
into but in 3d they really really stood
out because watching the trailers I'm
like okay well those I'm sure it's be a
fine 3d movie but ended up being a lot
more worth it than I initially thought
because a lot of it left out of the
trailers that I thought was great here
but let's talk about the actual movie
here let's take this series up it is the
worst Marvel totally ruins the
continuities craps all over the let me
see ingame no no this movie I I think
it's great I liked him a lot more I
don't know if I liked it a lot more yeah
I liked it a lot more I've decided I
like it a lot more
you heard hydro-man homecoming my
emotions have caught up to me John tell
him what the movies about the movie is
about wouldn't you know it Peters
struggling to balance his personal life
with his spider-man life as his class
prepares to take a trip across Europe
however there's an elementals attack
going on throughout Europe and Mysterio
has stepped in to try and fight so amid
all that here's Nick Fury coming to pull
spider-man into the game spider-man
doesn't want to be a part of the game
and spider-man far from home begin let's
get this out of the way
John how would you say it Tom Holland is
in the mood oh well eventually I mean
Tom Holliday is one of the most
wonderful characters to come to screen
Tom Hall is great in this movie he
continues and builds upon I think the
goodwill he built in that first in
homecoming because I mean I know for a
lot of people he has taken up the mantle
as being the definitive Peter Parker on
screen for me I still do have
attachments to Tobey Maguire and other
people but I think the cartoon more
trails in mind just you know keeping the
door open for some of those things I
think that Tom Holland has all those
charms from homecoming here but with an
added layer of emotional nuance and
emotional heft that he has to carry
through this movie that oddly enough I
felt the coming-of-age aspects even
harder in this one than the previous so
I thought he did a terrific job
apparently this moment doesn't have
audio of where I was talking about
specifically with Tom Hall's performance
but I really do want to mention that I
think the gravitas that he gives
especially in the second half of this
real emotional intensity and paranoia I
found to be very gripping I love the way
he provided anyway back to what's
actually captured in audio even though
the stakes are a lot bigger here and
then in homecoming
I found the inner conflict more
relatable and I think or personal yeah
because I think a lot of the credit goes
to the immediacy of Peter Parker's main
obstacle here which is he really just
wants to connect with MJ yeah and that's
something I think all of us can connect
with his wine to you know hook up with
the idea of like you what you really
want to woo someone getting nervous
about it do you have that I want to come
up with the perfect moment yeah exactly
so you have that element here I think
the chemistry between Peter Parker and
MJ is the biggest heart of the movie
yeah I love them together I'm rooting
for them I fell in love with their like
romantic relationship that they were
forming here and I think you guys will
too and if you've already seen it you
probably will agree with me they were
grades and day gets a lot more to do and
it gets a shine way more while the theme
of him having to balance personal life
and being spider-man is very familiar
it still feels really fresh in this
specific take because it's very much
akin to this specific interpretation we
have a Spider Man also the after-effects
of endgame are very much felt that are
establishing the sort of world that's
developed since you know post endgame
post Tony Stark and all that which I
thought they handled really well and had
a lot of levity and humor too a lot of
the traumatic weight of the situation
wasn't expecting this movie to fully do
and I thought they did it pretty well
that being said in terms of the movie
alone I think the first half of this
movie is fine I think it's really fun
it's really cute it's you know it's a
high school teen movie pretty much with
some spider-man stuff in there it's
really charming but it there was nothing
really in it in the first half that I
was like okay this this is your
follow-up to endgame alright sure this
is passable yeah you like the first half
could have used a couple more scenes to
maybe give it just a touch more weight
to support itself because it doesn't
feel quite as substantial as when the
movie truly kicks in about halfway
through well I think on a repeat viewing
I might enjoy it more especially being
aware of where it's gonna be going in
its second half this film really has a
pretty distinct two halves there's a
very pivotal moment where you're like
okay we have entered the second half of
the film and I think for me even saying
that you might be able to tell when
you're entering the second half of the
film well that's the thing I feel like
maybe with a couple more scenes I
wouldn't have been anticipating there
being such a shift you know but yeah we
won't get into that we can't get into
any of the second half unfortunately
hope is a future thing for Marvel where
like all the trailers are just this is
all the first half of the movie yeah no
idea what's coming at you because there
are a lot of surprises here that are
really thrilling yeah because I think
the first half still is a good build-up
to what you're gonna get in we're in the
second half who gets really intense very
gripping the humor doesn't go away in
fact it actually I think it kind of gets
funnier yeah because of how intense
everything has become yeah yeah and the
way that they're able to effectively
draw the kind of bumper cars of all the
different things he's trying to manage
at once because it is just like a
stressful it's yeah kind of cures the
problem that a lot of spider-man and
super
hero movies have of being bloated
because Peter is like overwhelmed with
all the things you hang on so it makes a
lot of sense it's smooth the plot it
streamlines yeah and I'm there scenes in
the second half visually that I will not
leave my mind it just I keep whenever I
flash to this movie I think of certain
keynote moments between Mysterio and
spider-man that I cannot tell you about
they're just so what it was yeah yeah
well I oughta Blee said it and I heard
people around me you've seen a variety
of like wow oh my god and these moments
occurred yeah and that's part of the
magic I think of the MCU especially is
the way they've been able to realize
those things because you know you can
you can argue you can argue that you
know in a lot of these stories there are
similar powers between the heroes and
the villains and whatnot a lot lately it
seems like they are bringing in
interesting filmmaking techniques and
visual elements with their characters
true and that keeps things really fresh
so yeah I'm like Mysterio he's got some
amazing visual realization yeah so Jake
Gyllenhaal's portrayal is what I thought
I feel like with Michael Keaton as
vulture Michael Keaton really elevated
that role while I think Jake Gyllenhaal
go into anything what he does with the
Mysterio character is special but I also
felt the writing really cared a hell of
a lot yes when I think I'm spider-man
far from home I also view it as
Mysterio's movie as well and that's
probably a big difference as a pair
stuff it's a homecoming which is pretty
much as the Peter Parker spider-man
movie I like how it managed to get
bigger but still feel pretty much
contained there are a lot of different
locations there is some pretty you know
destructive action and yet it doesn't
feel like a world ending Apocalypse Now
funny it highlighted to me the
juxtaposition of the theme that Peter
wants to be a neighborhood spider-man
and not so much an Avenger this time and
I think the movie again encapsulate that
scale to the action in here is much
better than homecoming it's more clear
sequins is in here that reminded me more
of the the rainy day
there's no spider-man fight scene and
homecoming that really stands out to me
and then here there there are shots and
sweeping epic moments robbers just like
wow cool yeah
those breathtaking imaginative
comic-book my action ideas to life or
cartoon ideas to life and I like the
evolution of his powers and what the
urge and how they're choosing to handle
him growing into an ultimate spider-man
as opposed to like you know oh he's got
every power equipped like as you saw an
infinity of war they tease the spider
sense is won't say much other than
that's a approach to for this that his
powers may develop and grow over time
because that makes ya more interesting
as he grows as a character - there's
this storyline with Ned this is really
funny I think some people have
complained about it I personally thought
it was really funny how they executed
yeah okay I can see I guess how some
people might think it's kind of a
one-note gag that repeats a whole lot
that's not really a character in here
yeah he doesn't really get yeah there
are a few things that sort of become
that but I
you can't flesh out both net and MJ in
the same movie yeah head gets homecoming
MJ gets bar from oh that's one of those
things that in the the give-and-take of
the match I'm like okay it's not
absolutely important that we do that and
and you do appreciate the team comedy
elements that that also kind of genre
splices yes - yeah Nick Fury he's good
he's good
his best lines are probably in the
trailer yeah yeah is good cobie smulders
is there yeah in there I have an issue
with the way they handle Aunt May um
we'll talk about in our spoiler review I
have an issue I don't feel like she's
much of a character which he had plenty
of scenes where she could have been yeah
and I think Cobie Smulders didn't wanna
be in this it's strange because she she
is the one character who shows up more
than a lot of people and doesn't get
that much to do she has like zero
emotion in this movie she's clearly a
bad she's like Nick Fury's
right hand like better do some stuff or
something I don't know if it was a
choice based off some stuff that happens
in the movie but yeah I just felt like
she didn't want to be there yeah and it
is kind of a detriment I think at least
less in this movie than in homecoming
but the Peters family life is kind of
just removed I know we've talked about
this before you don't really feel like
there's any kind of presence of Uncle
Ben and so that does leave his and Mei
relationship also kind of healing I
think because they just don't want to
even acknowledge it my issue with it
basically like this isn't a spoiler my
issue with it is now at homecoming to
have that cliffhanger wid yeah then she
finds out he's spider-man you say sure
the end game gap and everything an
infinity war like all that time span of
whatever happened their relationship but
there's like no depth or weight to the
dynamics in their relationship she's
still essentially just hot aunt and I
kind of I'm annoyed by that [ __ ] but I
think she seems more of a support to
enhance the happy Hogan character who
Jon Favreau is great in the movie Anna
Mae is kind of reduced to that just a
punchline I kind of don't get the
character yeah it's in the trailer you
fast forward to the point where she's
like pimping spider-man out all over
town but she does yeah like she seems to
have no awareness that that's still your
nephew and he's 16 years old yeah like
you don't act like a guardian in any way
yeah overall I mean this movie
definitely delivered on being as
heartwarming and kind of fun as
homecoming is but also like heavy to a
degree propre Utley following endgame
and also setting up some really
wonderful surprises and really wonderful
things for the future so yeah I was
pretty dazzled and I really enjoyed this
most of there's post-credits and these
are like must-see post-credit they are
both yeah I couldn't believe how many
people left have you never been to a
Marvel movie yeah and the thing is these
post-credits scenes are not just like
fun things or they're essential
post-credit scenes a really weird part
is like the first post-credit scene is a
little bit bigger than the whole movie
yeah there's lots more shocking than
anything else that happened yeah and I
heard that and then I watched it I'm
like oh wow that is great
yeah no matter how many times people
prepped me for something shocky night
not predict an out thing you will either
this movie has a lot of heart definitely
recommend it it's not just some and man
in the wasp situation of like all rights
go back to some fun no I think this is a
necessary movie for the MCU and I think
it's a great way to conclude things
after endgame surprisingly look at that
that's probably the bigger surprise like
yeah this perfectly works it's a nice
ribbon on it all all right guys well you
see spider-man far from home keep a look
out for our spoiler review excited to be
doing that you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell who which spider-man villain do you
want to see up here and make sure to go
watch this RealD 3d or 40x
or both if you can